what's your question man so no honestly the course is amazing digital landlords i wish
i've been putting more time into it i'm so busy with sco clients and they take up so much of my
time i keep putting out fires every single day i just want to give a big shout out to you but
also want to ask you would you recommend kind of burning the boats and ditching some of these
clients in order to free up more time or do you have any recommendations for outsourcing
so i definitely like when i started scaling first of all is this it's kind of a contextual
question because if you need it to pay the bills and it's keeping you out of your job then that's
one thing but i also know that it could be the thing that's causing you not to scale because
your attention is definitely going to be split what i did again this is just from experience
is in 2020 when i started scaling is i found a strategic partner i created the strategic partner
it was my employee that was doing my seo he started a company we did a 50 50 split he would
sign the deal i'd sign the deals i'd send them to him i wouldn't talk to the client again he would
pay me 50 of the net profit that allowed me to keep some of the money but also just to focus
strictly on lead generation so that's what i did it worked out really really well i still was able
to make about and and every time i use i say i made 100k a month i hope you guys know that was
just with lead gen this was when i talked seo that was just like gravy um we did we were doing like
seven to twelve thousand a month my split of seo which means i could have taken 20 if i would have
done it myself but i just decided you know i could take 15 to 20 but i decided i'm going to take
half of that focus on lead gen because that's where i could actually scale so that's what i
would recommend as far as like outsourcing i don't really have any one that i've used that
i would recommend uh look i can ask around and and get that for you it's just difficult when
you're when you're doing like white labeling because people do the bare minimum uh you know
they just want to get paid and they don't really care uh but you can shoot me a message and i can
you know maybe there's some some some kind of a way we could you could even use my team
uh i don't know but yes if you want to send me a message i'm happy to do that man
all right man you have a good one bro appreciate you hopping on uh hey good luck with the hurricane
if you could get get us some get some good photos for the websites dude let's get some
some some storm damage yeah maybe that's a good one all right i'll try my best
hey good to talk to you man we'll talk soon later nate